wir hören dass es gesundheitsminister
jens spahn den umständen entsprechend
gut geht er hat in einer ersten reaktion
exklusiv gegenüber bild gesagt ich würde
heute positiv auf dass corinna virus
getestet ich befinde mich in häuslicher
isolation und habe bisher nur
erkältungssymptome entwickelt also
bislang nur erkältungssymptome offenbar
hat er auch kein fieber allerdings wir
wissen beim corona virus kommt es vor
allem auf die entwicklung in den
nächsten tagen an
und seit wann ist die krone infektion
von jens spahn bekannt wir wissen davon
seit 16 uhr 59 heute da kam die
eilmeldung über die agenturen das hier
einsparen positiv getestet wurde
es ist so dass er laut seinem sprecher
hanno kautz der übrigens genauso wie der
minister und andere seiner mitarbeiter
ebenfalls jetzt in häuslicher quarantäne
häuslicher isolation sich befindet
positiv getestet wurde er wurde dort mit
einem schnelltest im
gesundheitsministerium getestet und dort
kam der das ergebnis positiv heraus er
befindet sich jetzt in häuslicher
isolation ist zu hause